the cries of a baby filmed by the woman
who wanted to adopt him but ended up
shaking him to death
leland james corkhill was murdered by
the woman who should have done
everything to protect him but a woman
who when she heard a baby crying in
hospital
filmed herself reacting like this
then i just stood up like that i went
right
and he fell off the floor
laura castle initially told police
leland james death was an accident an
independent review of the case has found
she also lied to social services about
hitting him information she had anger
management issues and was drinking six
bottles of wine a week wasn't passed on
had the adoption panel had we known the
full breadth there's no doubt we would
have been able to have considered the
vulnerabilities and risks more
effectively and that's the conclusion of
the report today it was a happy go-lucky
la laday he was always laughing always
smiling
for leela and james's grandmother the
questions of how this could have
happened have never gone away
he would have been better off staying
with his mum
it would have been still a year behind
obviously he went to his mum they should
resign
they don't so
they just carry on and they know that
they ultimately for another kid will be
going to the set another family could
say everything could happen again i hope
there is some justice for him like we
want justice for the baby i mean they
don't they can't defend the cells or
anything yeah they shouldn't go through
it
for what happened to leland james laura
castle was sentenced to life in prison
agencies which should have shared
information didn't
there was another child living in the
home at the time and the report says
that following leland james's death that
child was able to give a very clear
account of what had been going on the
recommendations say the children in that
situation need to be listened to just
one more small change that could have
made a difference whilst the review was
very clear that this death wasn't
preventable um there certainly was
learning uh that came out of this review
and that key learning for me is really
around the need to seek out information
and to to challenge professionally
between agencies
and to just to really try to get
behind
what is presented by individuals and
address any concerns
laura castle's lies mean we may never
know exactly what happened to leland
james on the day he died when so many
young lives may depend on learning the
lessons greg milam sky news barrow
infiness